wo ist wohl das komplexeste spiel in dem
sich bisher mensch und computer gemessen
haben oder computer hat jetzt zum ersten
mal gegen den weltbesten spieler
gewonnen
das programm alpha wovon sieht meint
besiegte den weltbesten fußballer die
künstliche intelligenz ki entwickelt
sich immer weiter und auch die software
ag ist jetzt bereit für die nächsten
aufgaben was das sein wird und ob uns
gefahr von kiwi alpha gedroht das jetzt
sehen die zum teil zuwächsen herzlich
willkommen
als ibm computer deep blue genau vor 20
jahren 1997 den damaligen
schachweltmeister garri kasparow in
einer regulären partie bezwang brachen
neue zeiten an
doch der von fans jungs zu erschaffen
rechner war er ein computer
leistungs-riese wer einfach wahnsinnig
viele stellungen im voraus berechnen
konnte in der endausbau phase 200
millionen stellungen pro minute als
günstig intelligenz spall fango ist das
anders
es ist eine künstliche intelligenz die
zudem geschafft hat den weltbesten
spieler in einem spiel zu schlagen
das weitaus komplizierter als faches es
gibt deutlich mehr möglichkeiten als
beim schach und ein weiterer meilenstein
wurde vor kurzem erreichte crm-software
librettos ist sogar in der lage spiele
mit unvollständiger informationen wie
poker zu spielen
im gegensatz zu oder schach liegen hier
durch die verdeckten karten viele
informationen nicht vor alpha group
wurde zu beginn der entwicklung erst mal
mit millionen verschiedener züge
besonders guter groß spieler gefördert
dann spielt die software gegen sich
selbst und ermittelte wie sie am besten
gewinnen konnte so trainiert wie könnte
hier intelligent durch menschen wohl
nicht mehr bequem war dabei hatte der
weltmeister ein vorteil des menschen
gegenüber dem computer aus genutzt und
zwar die kreativität der eröffnete die
partie mit einem absolut unüblichen zug
dort werden
das nützt nichts alfaro hatte damit
keinerlei probleme und gewandt jetzt
soll das programm weiterentwickelt
werden und die menschheit bei der lösung
schwierige aufgaben helfen zitat
wissenschaftlern helfen einige unserer
größten probleme anzupacken etwa neue
krankheits therapien zu finden
den energieverbrauch zu reduzieren und
revolutionäre neue materialien finden
das sagt denise verfahrens der
entwickler von alfra go so könnte die
software komplexe aufgabe wie günstige
transportwege oder optimierung von
energienetzen übernehmen hier gibt es ja
nicht so viele werte die in die
berechnung einfließen dass es nur eine
ki hier wirklich in der lage ist neue
lösungen zu finden aber auch bei der
entwicklung neuer medizinischer
wirkstoffe könnte all helfen
es gibt also eine menge zu tun
allerdings machen etwas stutzig und
skeptisch die entwicklerfirma dietmann
wurde inzwischen von einem der größten
it konzerne der welt gekauft google und
bei google steht datenschutz nicht
gerade im mittelpunkt der strategie im
gegenteil google sammelt so viele daten
wie irgendwie geht und verkauft eltern
wiederum zum beispiel an werbekunden
ausgewertet von einer künstlichen
intelligenz könnten sie viel mehr wert
sein und wir könnten durch ganz einfach
manipuliert werden ich nehme mir vor
dass die ganzen des
informationskampagnen während des us
wahlkampfes auch noch von einer
künstlichen intelligenz koordiniert
worden wären
kaum auszumalen logging waren besser
aber auch massiv vor der kita befürchtet
dass sie uns von der erde verdrängt weil
wir mit der evolution einfach nicht
mithalten können ki entwickelt sich viel
schneller als der mensch und
überflügelten mit leichtigkeit und
zumindest balco hatten ja schon
geschafft mal schauen wie es weitergeht
und weise etwas neues gibt werde ich
hier auf die zum video sack zumachen
wenn ihr auf dem laufenden bleiben wollt
dann soll mir genau hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesse ich den auf die glocke
dann verpasst er kein video hier geht es
weiter mit videos mit stephen hawking
als einer der bedeutenden physiker
unserer zeit ist ja immer wieder für
eine überraschung gut und ansonsten bis
dann platzt